a recent poll shows working mothers have
been diagnosed with anxiety and or
depression 42 percent more than the
general population their co-workers
without kids and even working fathers
tonight some coping skills you can
Implement right now to help the pink
color recession had more than 2 million
women leaving the workforce during the
pandemic to care for their kids and
while many have returned there are
lasting impacts the Harris poll
commissioned by CVS Health four months
ago revealed 42 percent of working
mothers have been diagnosed with anxiety
or depression 33 percent say their
mental health declined in 2022 40
percent don't feel their mental health
will return to pre-pandemic days and 72
percent don't feel supported at work
working weathers are really facing a
challenge Dr Elizabeth arleo is a
professor of radiology at Cornell
University a working mom and author of
the book first eat your frog it offers
eight lessons or pearls for professional
working mothers she says feelings of
guilt remain for what children went
through during the pandemic or didn't
get to experience in terms of Milestones
moms in general still need time to heal
she has strategies that working mothers
can Implement right now it's best to
take care of the most important people
to you as early as possible in the day
or week or whatever time period you're
considering this is twofold first it
sets you up for Success because no
matter what happens you're taking care
of the most important thing and secondly
it lessens the mental load Dr arlio's
next tip is to think of time not as 24
hours in a day but as a week equaling
168 hours that way even if you work 50
hours a week sleep 56 hours a week
you've still got plenty of time for
other things I think that it it really
lessens the pressure because whereas you
can't have it all or do it all within 24
hours the fact of the math is is that
there is time there for your priorities
for yourself your family your friends
and your community
a third tip she says don't let perfect
be the enemy of good a reminder that
nothing's perfect set your criteria for
what you're looking to accomplish and
once you've met it move on to the next
task Elizabeth's book has many more tips
it comes out on International women's
day which is March 8th but you can
pre-order it now on Amazon Denise good